i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks
using my link below
we have not really talked about covid
for a while because it's become kind of
background noise to so many people
whether that's right or wrong i'm not
saying but it has become background
noise to a large share of the united
states
but we're currently in the middle of a
wave so massive that the real number of
infections
might be 500 000 infections per day
already already now
and you might say well but hold on a
second david those aren't the official
numbers right now and you would be
absolutely correct but i'll explain um
if you look at the official case numbers
you'll see that we're back up to about a
hundred thousand cases per day in fact
if i look at the absolute newest numbers
we're at about ninety nine thousand five
hundred cases per day so call it a
hundred thousand cases per day
but we're now at a point
where there's just a ton of sort of like
who cares around the country
and the belief is that we're capturing
maybe only one out of five actual
infections that we have now remember a
case is you've got a positive test an
infection is someone has the virus
whether it shows up as a positive test
or not and there's a few different
reasons that we are not capturing nearly
all of the infections number one
many people are just no longer getting
tested when they have symptoms oh i've
got symptoms yeah it's probably covered
or not i don't know but i'm just staying
home or maybe i'm not even staying home
if you're less responsible or unable to
um but that's an infection and it's not
showing up as a case that's that's first
and foremost number two
we have a ton of people getting home
tests and these home tests there's
nothing magical there's no
wi-fi bluetooth or rfid in your home
test if you test positive on a home test
and you don't report it anywhere that
also doesn't show up in the case numbers
even though it's an infection and then
thirdly there's essentially no more
testing of asymptomatic people going on
very sparingly there are places that are
doing surveillance testing uh meaning
everybody gets tested on some period of
time friends of mine and family who work
in academic settings some of them say
yeah we get tested once a week or twice
a week
um just to keep the campus sort of in a
regular testing mode but that's
basically gone away
and so asymptomatic people
are essentially not showing up anywhere
and so to get the real number of
infections we have to multiply by
roughly five says dr eric topple who has
a great twitter on covet stuff and he's
been a guest on the show meaning that
our 100 000 official cases per day
probably means around half a million
actual infections per day which is just
an incredible number now the good news
so far is that if we look at deaths
deaths continue to decline
and we typically believe there's about a
three or four week delay from when cases
increase
before you see an increase in deaths and
it's been two months of increasing cases
and deaths continue to decline
now down uh
technically below the level of flu
deaths in the united states in the sense
that if in the average oh i'm sorry no
that's completely wrong but i i
apologize that's not true at all
we average about a thousand flu death
i'm sorry 100 flu deaths a day in an
average flu season
um and we're at about 250 kova deaths a
day so still two and a half times as
many coveted deaths as flu deaths uh but
hospitalizations are going up so it is
very uh it's conceivable and plausible
that soon we are going to see the death
numbers go up as well we're already
seeing a 20 increase in hospitalizations
now in the meantime
we are learning many new things about
covid one of those is not a good piece
of news
it's that covid is now uh evolving
quickly enough
with enough variants that are we've had
variants forever but now the variants
actually seem to slightly more regularly
out compete each other as dr eric topel
has written about and this means that
more quickly we are getting variants
that can break through boosters
and can break through natural immunity
as well
to reinfect people potentially multiple
times per year that's very very much uh
not good now there is one bit of good
news if we want to look for one which is
that we're currently in what's being
colloquially called wave 5 or also known
as the ba 4 slash ba5 wave remember we
had the original omicron wave and then
uh the secondary omega okay so now we're
on ba 4 and ba 5 variants if you look at
south africa
you see that this wave five has already
leveled off and started to decline
and so
often times what happens in south africa
happens in the united states somewhere
around you know six eight ten weeks six
to eight weeks later
and we hope that that's the case and
that this is the peak but this is
these are incredible numbers half a
million infections believed per day
and one other element of this that's a
bit concerning is we may already be kind
of behind on vaccines the omicron
tailored vaccine
which is going to be tailored to the
first omicron variant back from uh
late november early december 2021
that vaccine is going to be out in a
couple of months and by then we're going
to be like five variants away so so from
that so there's a real question
as to whether we can even keep up or
catch up when it comes to vaccination
because
it takes a while to uh get the vaccines
updated so that's what's going on i'd be
curious to hear from you leave a comment
send an email send a tweet
at this point are you taking any covet
precautions at all i know many people in
the audience are taking full precautions
and many people in the audience are
taking absolutely no precautions at this
point in time as of what i heard from
you guys about a couple months ago let
me know where you are right now
i have for you today
an ultra viral video of former president
george w bush
with what is an incredible freudian slip
wherein he says that the iraq invasion
that he led in 2003
was brutal and unjustified and of course
that's correct but that's not what he
meant george w d this is really
unbelievable george w bush was speaking
uh at the george w bush institute this
week
about the russian invasion of ukraine
and during that speech
he meant to call the russian invasion of
ukraine
unjustified and brutal which is true
but he instead said iraq
and
he just sort of like laughs it off and
says hey i'm 75 years old now and we're
going to look at the video it's
disturbing to see one of the biggest
tragedies optional tragedies
of the century so far
reduced to a whoopsie i misspoke so take
a look at this video
17 million views in under 24 hours
so far
likely will get 30 40 million views
george w bush speaking about meaning to
speak about russia
but
slipping up in contrast
russian elections are rigged
political opponents
are imprisoned or otherwise eliminated
from participating in the electoral
process
the result is an absence of checks and
balances in russia
and
the decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of iraq i mean of
ukraine
all right anyway
75. uh
so he seems to say
iraq ii there and it's not clear if he's
joking but it's clear he didn't mean to
say that that was a slip up he
accidentally called his invasion of iraq
in 2003 brutal and unjustified and he
laughs it off
now there are people in the audience who
are young enough
that you may not remember the entire
lead-up to the iraq war or maybe even
know that much about it this was an
absolute tragedy based on false
information
linking iraq to the 911 attacks and
claiming iraq had weapons of mass
destruction which we can't ever say with
certitude they that they didn't have but
that were never found we can say
4 400 u.s armed forces were killed in
that optional misguided war
32 000 american troops were wounded in
action in that war
318 um
coalition forces were killed
16 000 iraqi military and police were
killed somewhere around 26 27 000 iraqi
insurgents were killed
136 journalists
and media worker another 50 media
workers were killed on duty covering
that war
and
population-based studies of iraq suggest
that the civilian casualties were
somewhere between and i know this is a
big range
civilian casualties in iraq during the
iraq war
were between 150 000
and a million excess deaths think about
those numbers think about the incredible
loss of life based on what were the
things that were being said at the time
at the time there were three main lies
that were being told which many
americans fell for particularly fox news
viewers we covered we covered this when
the show started the the war was still
going on it wasn't the beginning of it
but it was still going on the lie was
told that saddam had something to do
with 911 he didn't
the lie was told that iraq had weapons
of mass destruction if they had him they
were never found and the lie was told
that the world community was generally
supportive of the us invasion of iraq
the world community was not supportive
of that and on that lie and on a false
intelligence case made by colin powell
made by condoleezza rice
and the bush administration at large
somewhere between you know all told 200
000
and 1.1 1.2
million people died untold amounts of
money was spent and for those in our
audience too young to remember the
lead-up
it was really
it was the first time i saw firsthand
and experienced in a way that i could
sort of remember and understand it you
know during the first gulf war i was a
little kid in the early 90s and i
remember seeing
you know on tv my parents were watching
footage of what was going on uh but i
didn't really understand it
in uh 2003 i saw the drum beat we've got
to go we're going to have to go saddam's
a bad guy yellow cake uranium colin
powell making the case
using bad information and then we're
going to be greeted as liberators and
dick cheney's saying they're going to
throw roses at us i think he said and of
course it didn't happen and it was an
absolute and total disaster
so george w bush you know you can
analyze this a bunch of different ways
oh he's 75 he's just he's kind of losing
it he doesn't know what he's saying or
it was a very meaningful freudian slip
where he maybe now recognizes the
misguided nature
of that invasion my sense is i mean
listen i
i don't like
rewriting history
and making george bush out to be
anything better than what he was which
was a disaster
on basically every front but
in some way
with the benefit of hindsight i think if
you got bush in a room where there was
no media and he was just totally honest
with you
my sense is he probably would express
regrets about iraq i'm not saying that
it would be a complete 180 but i think
to some degree he realizes that it was
not worth it and that it was wrong i
don't know that he would ever say it i'm
speculating and i would like to believe
that that freudian slip
was in some way representative of what
he actually believes let me know what
you think incredible video monday
memorial day we are doing a big
membership blowout it'll be a one-day
discount we want to bring in as many new
people into the ranks of membership as
we can as we lead up to the midterm
elections of 2022 significant midterm
elections if you would like to get the
coupon code to sign up on memorial day
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds
this has happened to me before i've
talked on the show we got hacked it was
costly it wasn't a good feeling and
that's why i now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors protecting your
accounts and devices gets complicated
because you need a bunch of different
tools and aura combines them all into
one app identity theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different
data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below
in the immediate aftermath of this
horrible terrorist shooting incident in
buffalo new york over the weekend we
talked about it monday we talked about
it tuesday this was an individual a
white 18 year old domestically born
american who was specifically targeting
black people influenced by right wing
ideas regularly parroted out on fox news
including of the white replacement
theory or great replacement theory white
birth rates and other things in the
immediate aftermath of that i already
told you that there was a segment on fox
news where they did their normal dog and
pony show where they talk about violence
in video games is possibly a cause for
this shooting we've also seen the
promulgators of the exact same ideology
that the shooter cites in his manifesto
people like tucker carlson and others
say this was just a lone incident of
mental illness that's all it was there's
no politics here there's no ideology
there's no conservatism or liberalism
and we also saw ben shapiro say if there
is politics here it really sounds more
like wokeness than anything else which
is of course completely untrue the ideas
in the manifesto
are being espoused exclusively by
right-wing political commentators well
let me now show you some other attempts
to shift and place blame in absurd and
pathetic ways happening on fox news
jesse waters pulls out it's sort of like
i don't it's kind of like uh pulling
random reasons out of a hat a maga hat i
guess we could say
lockdowns
forced masking and woke ideology are
what jesse waters says
really we should be looking at as the
causes of the buffalo shooting take a
look at this this is from yesterday we
have a crisis right now the american
public education system is hurting our
kids
math and reading rates are plummeting
studies are showing that kids are
talking less
they're already warning about a third of
elementary school students need quote
intensive support but our leaders don't
care they're more concerned about how
they're going to force masks back on
kids
some school districts in california and
new jersey have just implemented fresh
mask mandates in classrooms this week
we're setting these kids up for failure
for a generation deep in a mental health
crisis after lockdowns forced masking
woke ideology kids are feeling depressed
just look at what happened in the
buffalo situation what a teenager whose
school system failed him decided his
only option was to turn to the dark web
where he was radicalized
a failed education system let that
happen but the so-called experts think
they haven't done anything wrong watch
so
has jesse waters seen the tucker carlson
show
because if so
he'd know exactly what inspired the
shooter the shooter's manifesto verbatim
has talking points from tucker carlson's
show in it
masking what
what and jesse waters brings up
fair and concerning things it is true
that covet-era babies many of them now
toddlers
seem to have something going on in terms
of language development i've read that
that's concerning we've got to deal with
that
shooter's 18.
okay the shooter was 16 when covet
started and the idea that that's what
left the shooter no choice but to go out
and target black people even if it were
the case that you had let
limited language development due to
masking doesn't make you go and target
black people it's a completely absurd
claim and they don't know what to do
they don't know what to say
because their ideology is verbatim in
the manifesto now by the way
constant mass shootings also aren't
happening in any other advanced country
where they had masking
and by sort of like nor you know what we
call normal schooling where you learn
empiricism and science and stuff like
that
they call it woke schooling they have it
in other countries as well and they
don't have the mass shooting problem one
thing they don't have is ready access to
so many guns the party of personal
responsibility as you can see
blaming the left for making this guy
murder innocent people this guy is a
complete and total joke now here's
another example this one's also from fox
news this is
kennedy lisa kennedy
she links
abortion
and the sort of disregard for human life
that she says is implicit in abortion
to shooting she says when we disregard
human life of course you get shootings
wild stuff just not and i know a lot of
people a lot of democrats who say i am
pro-choice but i don't believe that we
should be killing babies after 15 weeks
i certainly don't think that we should
be performing these procedures and
celebrating them at 20 weeks you have a
lot of democrats saying you know we used
to hear safe legal and rare you don't
hear that anymore you hear people
chanting about how great abortion is
regardless of how you feel about whether
or not the courts or congress should be
involved that is not something to be
celebrated and we have lost the plot as
a society so don't be surprised when
there are mass casualty events at the
hands of sociopaths we have so little
regard for human life and that starts
with basic decent conversations where we
have mutual dignity and curiosity we
have to find a way to get back to that
place even when we disagree vehemently
so you think that people who seek
abortions are sociopaths no i'm saying
that mass shooters are sociopaths mass
shooters and people like that are raised
to have very little respect for human
life and i think we have to get back to
a place in society where we do have
respect for each other where you don't
have people going on the subway and
shooting people and trying to okay so
it's it's a very very dumb show but her
argument is
mass shooters don't have respect for
life and for society
and people who gleefully get abortions
as she claims people do don't have
respect for life in society and so the
link is
in general when you don't have respect
for life and society you either go and
get abortions or you go and do a mass
shooting it's hard to imagine a dumber
take it truly is
but they are desperate to blame anything
they can
other than looking inward and i get it
it's hard to look inward when when the
blame is on you and again we're not
saying legal blame but when we what we
are saying is
the ideology espoused by the shooter's
manifesto
is an ideology that has been nurtured
and incubated in right-wing media and
fox news is part of it whether kennedy's
herself talked about white replacement
theory or not i don't know maybe she
didn't but at this point there's no way
that she could not realize that many of
the people on her network are the ones
pushing the same stuff that was in the
manifesto you look everywhere else
abortion's the reason
uh or masking or woke education or
whatever the case may be they're not
going to look inward uh but we have to
remember that we know exactly why the
shooter did what they did hey this is
very very interesting i finally was able
to get on truth social truth social is
the uh trumpian social media platform
that trump seems unable to pronounce
correctly truth essential exactly truth
sensual i finally was able to get on
truth social because they now you can
just sign up on a desktop computer you
don't need to have a particular phone
now to do it
so you can find me on truth social at
dpakman i'm just trolling on there i'll
probably get banned
but
i realized when looking around
that on election day tuesday before and
after the election
failed former president donald trump was
engaged in just a dystopian
authoritarian series of screeds and
posts i don't know what they don't call
them tweets because it's not twitter
although they basically copied twitter
to design the site
check out the stuff that donald trump
was posting um throughout the day and
then after so trump posting remember all
three candidates in pennsylvania were
ultra maga so what trump was doing there
was hedging his endorsement trump
endorsed memit oz and we still don't
know who actually won that primary but
trump was trying to basically say
whether it's dave mccormick or kathy
barnett or memit oz it's all a win for
trump because they're all ultra mega so
that was trump hedging earlier in the
day
but then here's the really scary post
as has happened before in other
elections including with donald trump's
in 2020
we didn't have the results around 11 p.m
or midnight eastern on election day and
donald trump posted to troth central
quote dr oz should declare victory it
makes it much harder for them to cheat
with the ballots that they quote just
happen to find end trump's quote and end
full quote that's an authoritarian
nightmare and that is exactly you know
when we go back to trump coming out at
2am on election day in november of 2020
and saying we won when he very clearly
hadn't won it wasn't clear he lost but
it was very clear he hadn't yet won
he's admitting what the game is here you
say you won you just take credit for it
and it makes it harder than and it
poisons the well where people say i
don't know i mean he claimed victory he
must have won
trump then attacking fox news saying fox
news had a really bad night they were
way off on the count in timing in the oz
vote anybody watching would have said it
was over when actually it was just the
opposite i assume the coverage was being
led by the same guy that called arizona
who believe it or not they brought back
i want his agent now of course trump
continues to insist that he actually won
arizona it is not true joe biden won
arizona joe biden won arizona uh by any
measure of how you count ballots and
trump continues to lie about that
and then trump posting another one of
these truths which are actually lies
quite kafka-esque quote the fake news
media is having a really time really
hard time saying that magga and trump
didn't have anything but a spectacular
evening of voting and winning hold on
the best is yet to come now of course uh
madison cawthorne lost after just 16
months in office some trumpists won some
trump is lost but understand that the
game is
endorse mostly people who we know are
going to win with or without trump's
endorsement and then take credit for it
it is a nightmare on truth social if
you're curious it's sort of masochistic
i get it but if you're curious i'm on
there at least until they ban me uh i'm
deep hackman on truth troth truth
essential yeah exactly we'll take a
quick break and be right back after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
use the coupon code better21 for a huge
discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
professor baruch fishoff who is a
professor at carnegie mellon university
where he studies how experts and
non-experts think about
risks it's really great to have you on i
appreciate your time today
oh thanks for having me david so risk is
a very interesting topic because
much like this is a bad analogy but much
like when we come across a yellow light
when driving and we are intuitively
making a number of calculations that
make us decide to either go through the
light or not
we are thinking about the the risks to
us of all sorts of different activities
all the time and
the first part i think maybe that would
make sense to start with is
are human intuition intuitions about
risk generally reliable or
or not so much where we have to
sometimes step back and say am i
actually evaluating this risk correctly
well we're generally pretty good
particularly where we have good sources
of information or we have the same risk
see the same risk time and again i have
a chance for trial trial and error but
when something is new and we don't have
unreliable sources then we can uh
you know we can be in trouble
so i would say for example uh pittsburgh
is a has a driving culture where
people run the reds and i grew up in
detroit where people are much more
drivers are much more
disciplined so if i had i have
well-tuned intuitions for detroit
driving took me a while to get right
to
adjust them for pittsburgh driving
so
one uh
line that's often repeated for people
who are afraid of flying in on
commercial aviation is you know it's
really safe it's actually more dangerous
to drive to the airport statistically
than the flight itself and then when you
investigate that you find out that well
yes that's that's true in a way but what
it's looking at is based on passenger
miles and because airplanes are much
faster than cars you're traveling many
more miles and maybe
it's true but the the risk difference is
not as big as some might say with
something like that
how is how is the average human
to use that to assess is flying safe
enough for me because most of us don't
think about well what's my risk of dying
per thousand miles driven we just sort
of have a sense of do i know people who
have died in car accidents could i get
into a car accident and survive and most
of us make the decision that we're
willing to drive around but are those
comparisons useful
not really i think just for the reason
that you uh that you cited is that
uh often people who give us those
comparative risk statistics are really
they're trying to work us they're trying
to get us to do something like like fly
or drive or you know wear a mask or wash
our hands or
or whatever it's it's difficult to find
often difficult to find statistics
that are just presented in a trustworthy
way that aren't slanted that are really
relevant to our to our our are the art
our decisions and and in situations like
that we're really we depend on people to
you know to do that work for us i saw a
report this morning
about one of the things that i wear a
mask still this is
uh may 18 may 19th 2022 and that's
because i think there's a lot of
uncertainty about long covid
and there was a long report i think by
well-meaning people with a long report
in one of our major newspapers about
about a study showing that long covid is
very common among relatively young
people
but what they didn't tell us is well how
good is the measurement of non-co
long cove
are the observations for people who've
gotten it from omicron or the earlier
variants where
where the problems were much greater and
then how many people did they have in
each group like in the data set that
they had there were relatively few
people over 60 65
and but that seems to be because they
just didn't have a lot of observations
from people over 65 so it didn't didn't
answer my question what's the chance of
my getting long covered if i um
you know if i'm exposed and it certainly
didn't answer the question of well if i
get long cover what's the chance i'm
going to give it um get covert long
cover i'm going to give it to my wife or
you know or to somebody else so that's
what we really count on the experts to
work up the data in an honest way for us
it turned out to be it requires some
skill
also presenting the data in a way that
it's sort of useful to people seems like
it's a skill
as well i i recently read whether this
is accurate or not it doesn't really
matter but i recently read
that for someone without pre-existing
conditions the risk of dying from covid
is the same as dying in a car accident
for ten thousand miles driven and i was
thinking to myself is that high or low i
don't really know what that is it's it's
sort of a strange comparison to make how
do i even evaluate that yeah yeah and
and in addition you're making a dis your
risks and benefits are different in the
two
two situations you get some benefit from
taking a long trip you have a different
set of benefits from
you know from um you know making a
statement or having to fight to be the
person who's wearing uh who's wearing
them wearing a mask he really wants some
what you would really would like is
somebody just to give you the numbers
to say
you know if you if you take this trip uh
um you have one chance
an average car trip i think you have
about one chance in 10 million of being
in a fatal accident
and the risk is even smaller if you're
not drinking or driving uh early sunday
sunday morning so give me the numbers
people can handle those numbers and let
me decide don't don't try to work me
can you talk a little bit about when we
measure risk the difference between
absolute and relative risks right so so
something can double your risk of of uh
of uh you know something terrible
happening to you but it makes a big
difference whether that takes it from
one in a million to two in a million or
from one in a hundred to two and a
hundred so you really need the absolute
numbers the the absolute risk numbers in
order to make the risk benefit uh
trade-offs because you're trading
absolute benefits against absolute
absolute risk so those those relative
risks are are really meaningless they're
often misleading
so one example would be in medical
science reporting we often will read
that a certain food for example might
increase the risk or decrease the risk
of say uh you know a type of cancer by
forty percent and that's a very big
number forty percent but what you're
saying is it might be the difference
between a lifetime risk of one percent
and one point four percent and we need
to have that information to really
accurately assess what it means
exactly i have some friends or
colleagues at the dartmouth medical
school who have developed a
drug fact box like the nutrition fact
box that shows you the probability of
things going right and going wrong if
you take different drugs and absolute
absolute statistics and that's
information that's even hard for doctors
to know
so one of our examples is
is uh is a sleeping pill and that you
find that people who take the sleeping
pill fall asleep in 37 minutes compared
to people don't take the sleep pill fall
asleep on average in 45 minutes
and then they tell you what are the in
absolute numbers what are the the
side effects with and without the scene
well that's that's what you need to know
and and you and i might make those eight
minutes might mean a lot to me and uh
not a lot to you relative to the
to the side effects
one of the recent ones speaking of
medications and side effects has been
around covid vaccines uh where there
seem to be
some strange risk i call them strange
i'll see if you agree strange risk
assessments when it comes to
risks of the vaccine
specifically as compared to risks of
covid so for example
when you considered at one point
myocarditis was one topic that was quite
present and there was a lot of talk of
the risk of myocarditis from the vaccine
and absent from many of those
conversations was the relative uh
relatively higher risk of myocarditis
from covid and very often it seemed like
the consideration people were making was
what's my risk of myocarditis from the
vaccine
versus zero when really it should be
compared to the risk from myocarditis
from kovid should it not
oh
exactly and it is it is a persistent
puzzle why
people who are you know very dedicated
to our public health people who are very
dedicated to our health and our safety
and
why they don't know that
and and i think i think it's i mean i
have a lot of respect for public health
people
they're dedicated they're often brave
they expose themselves they work long
hours
but but i do i think they don't they
lack three they get into these problems
three things one is they don't know how
to do risk analysis
the second is that their inclination is
to tell people what to do rather than to
empower people to make their own
decisions and the third is they never
test their messages and if you think
we've got a you know wonderfully
heterogeneous country where people have
different backgrounds and different
different desires you can't imagine a
technical expert can't assume that what
makes sense to them will make sense to
the people that they're talking to and
it is easy to test your messages like
draft a message
let a few diverse people look at the
message read it
read it aloud tell you whatever comes
into their mind and you're always
surprised by things you thought were
clear that confused them
things that didn't confuse them but they
misinterpreted things that
that you forgot to say that you thought
were common knowledge and things about
your tone that they found disrespectful
where you thought was
i thought it was fine but
you tick them off so it's easy to test
messages they rarely do it
one of the things that relates to risk
assessments
i'm reminded of when years ago i read
the book thinking fast and slow by
daniel kahneman and he talks about a lot
of cognitive biases and heuristics that
affect our thinking about things and
some of them that seem very relevant to
risk assessment would be for example
framing things as the possibilities of
losses versus the possibilities of gains
he did some very interesting work
wherein uh he would sort of set up like
lottery type experiments where in sum
there's a probability of a gain and
others a probability of a loss but the
expected values just thinking
mathematically of these scenarios were
absolutely identical in principle humans
rationally thinking should be
indifferent between these scenarios but
we found out that framing things as
losses versus gains had a major impact
on people's willingness to take risks in
sort of gambling type situations can you
talk a little bit about
real world scenarios not imaginary
lotteries but real world scenarios where
that cognitive bias has a real impact in
people's decisions
so donna kahneman was one of my doctoral
advisors oh no way
along with uh almost
his uh his late late yeah
so uh i even have a cameo role in that
in the in the in the in the book so one
thing to know about the kind of research
that that psychologists do is we look at
situations where people have not figured
out what to do
and those are situations with that from
a scientific respect that are revealing
a fundamental thought proc of
cognitive processes emotional processes
where in everyday life
those situations can be fairly rare
that is you've learned what to do by
trial and error or somebody you trust
has told you what to uh
has told you what what what to do you've
watched what other people do and they
seem to be getting along with things and
uh and and so on so so the
our research tends to accentuate the
negative because look for problems and
because that just the way our our
science science goes thick uh
situations like the pandemic
put us in a situation where we don't
really know what you know where put us
into situations where these kinds of
biases or framing effects are most
effective because we don't really know
what to do we don't really know who to
trust people we talk to have all sorts
of different
different different ideas and
you know one bit of advice is to talk to
different people and and
they may none of them may know the right
answer but they will they have different
ways of looking at the problem and you
can decide well what way do i want to
frame it do i want to be thinking about
this as a loss or a loss or a gain
another thing a bit of advice i think
like that the literature would i think
support is don't beat yourself up too
much
these are legitimately difficult
decisions partly because they're novel
and the stakes are high but partly
because uh the experts have failed us
they haven't given us statistics that
they want they've manipulated the
statistics as you know as you suggested
uh have you suggested uh
earlier so we're really you know
sort of on our on our own so you know
find somebody who you people you trust
run it by a few other people if you've
done the best you can and things don't
work out you know don't don't add the
insult of
regret to the injury that you've already
suffered
one really difficult area when it comes
to taking a risk assessment and making
policy and economic decisions
is
really unlikely events
with an absolutely catastrophic impact
where our standard expected value type
calculations might not be very
informative one such would be
you know the
the the number that's often stated is
the odds of a meteor
with at least a one kilometer uh
diameter hitting earth
is basically one every 500 000 years is
when we would expect it now that could
be in two years although maybe astronomy
is good enough that we would know if it
would be in two years but in theory it
could be in two years or it could be in
499
998 years so in such a situation where
it's a very low likelihood but
absolutely catastrophic it can be
difficult
to know how much money should be
invested in technology to save us from
that
should we how much should we invest in
the technology that would allow us to
redirect or blow up such a meteor
how
how can humans think about things on
that scale so catastrophic but so
unlikely
i mean one thing to yeah but one thing
to ask is well
well what what would we get for our
money
sure
great ideas for what to do about it then
it's a it's a poor investment and in our
own lives if we can't do anything about
it why uh why why worry about it so
sometimes it pays to worry about
relatively small risks if we can do
something to reduce them or can put
ourselves in a situation where we
feel like i've done everything i could
and i'm just going to hope for the best
yeah i mean i guess the difficulty is
again if we when we start to get to such
large numbers it's sort of like thinking
about a billion years ago and that's
very hard for most
some of these the scale of some of these
things is hard for the average human to
sort of think of or you know a trillion
dollars what does that really mean
relative to the average average annual
budget uh if you if you were to shrink
it down
there's probably some
very small risk when anyone drives a car
not of a car accident but i'm talking
about a mechanical failure that
undetected
would almost certainly explode your car
and you could make the decision to check
that thing every time you drive but none
of us really do because we've assessed
the risk is so small it it
is that a better example to think
through how we would evaluate whether
action or inaction is the right path
yeah if there's nothing you can do
don't worry about it so
people
some i recently saw advice that if
you're really worried about leaving the
gas on
take a picture of your burners before
you leave the house
so there's something you can do it
doesn't right change the risk in case
they were a little ajar but it does put
your mind at ease you
you know with a modern cars you can't
really look under the hood and figure
out whether everything anything is going
wrong it would be fortunate if you're in
a state like pennsylvania that has
mandatory safety checks every uh every
year and we've been doing we've been
here 35 years and every few years they
find something you know that they
wouldn't have known
of otherwise so there's a place where i
think
i think government coercion as some
people would call it
has served us well
very interesting we've been speaking
with professor baruch fischoff who
teaches at carnegie mellon university
really appreciate your time and your
insights today oh thanks thanks for the
conversation
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind-the-scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's talk about a new
movement within the republican party and
the question at the end that i want to
come back to is is this a net good or a
net bad for the united states of america
so madison cawthorne radical trumpist uh
republican congressman madison cawthorne
after just 16 months in office is
already on his way out he will be
leaving in january he lost his primary
to a challenger in north carolina on
tuesday and at least part of the reason
that madison cawthorne lost is that he
became the focus or the target um of
what we might call establishment
republicans madison cawthorne has had a
bunch of run-ins with the law a couple
of uh very high-speed
speeding and potentially reckless
driving incidents involving his vehicle
um three times caught bringing a firearm
trying to bring firearms through tsa
security and bringing a gun to a school
i'm sorry a knife to a school council
meeting of some kind and then saying
that he gets invited to cocaine field
orgies by other members of congress and
it became very clear
that the republican party establishment
decided we're going after this guy and
they succeeded
the group that released some of the
controversial videos of madison
cawthorne say that they are going to be
targeting radical trumpist lunatic
congresswoman lauren bober next business
insider reporting madison cawthorne foes
who targeted him with a damaging new
nude video say lauren bobert is next on
their hit list the group that posted a
viral sexually explicit video of a nude
congressman madison cawthorne with
another man in bed is now focusing on
colorado representative lauren beaubert
for its next takedown insider has
learned david wheeler who's the
co-founder of the american muckrakers
pack said to insider quote i think we're
going to go after lauren beaubert and
colorado in a similar way
i think we're going to engage in that
race pretty quickly
wheeler is a democrat his co-founder is
unaffiliated the group has republicans
among its advisors wheeler said he's
received interesting information about
the republican firebrand bobert whose
primary against republican state senator
don quorum is on june 28th the
information is quote certainly not as
salacious as some of the cowthorne stuff
it deals instead with financial matters
and he didn't yet disclose more of it a
spokesperson for beau bert did not
immediately respond to a request for
comment now as the article points out
previously lauren bobert has also had
issues when it comes to campaign finance
last year the ap reported that bobert
failed to disclose her husband's income
during the campaign in violation of
ethics and campaign finance laws she
revealed her husband made nearly a
million dollars in 2019 and 2020 as a
consultant for an energy firm um so
what's the what's the question that we
have to ask here
is this good or bad for the country and
what do i mean by that well it's
abundantly clear
that there are far less crazy
republicans out there and that as a
general thing replacing a crazy
republican with a less crazy republican
is good in a sense
but at the same time
if the less crazy republicans can get
things done
versus these wild trumpists who say a
lot of wacky things but don't get
anything done and sometimes even get
kicked off of committees
is the country better off with the
crazier republicans in office i mean
marjorie taylor green is a good example
marjorie taylor green
was stripped of her committee
assignments
and
essentially has no influence in the
house of representatives okay you could
find some areas around the fringes where
maybe she is influencing someone but
very very little
um matt gates has some influence but
also he he's kind of a laughing stock
if you replace those people
with
you know hard-working
um kind of buttoned up republicans
if the if you replace them with people
like mitt romney who would would
certainly get fewer headlines but might
be more effective at getting legislation
passed or uh whipping votes or whatever
the case may be
is the country better off or not
obviously when you take a very wide view
and you say well listen the if you take
eight outrageous lunatic republicans and
replace them with people with whom you
know we kind of like we disagree on
taxes and abortion but they're not out
of their minds it sounds like that's an
improvement but at the same time if they
can actually accomplish things maybe
it's better to have the wackier people
in office i want to hear from you
and you know this is also a conversation
which we may be having in the context of
2024 because we talk about desantis
versus trump if they both were to run
for the republican nomination in 24
desantis
is almost as crazy as trump
but he's far more competent and so in
reality are we better off with trump
even though he's more of a global
laughing stock i don't know this is a
prediction
it's an it's a guess it's an estimate
it's not something we can say for sure
in advance but i want to hear from you
about it let me know your thoughts
they are continuing to attack dr anthony
fauci they want to see him in prison
many of them do
for what crime we don't really know and
the latest is that donald trump's former
economic advisor uh peter navarro
says that he will force fauci to admit
that he created covid now how that if
it's the china virus as they say
and china created it how is it that
fouchy created it it doesn't really make
sense we're going to look at this clip
and consider how extreme
how dangerous
how disturbing it is
that
they want to go after
medical doctors who just give us their
best advice at the time these are sick
people here's peter navarro on newsmax
listen to this here's your future tony
republicans are going to sweep and take
the house back from nancy pelosi and as
soon as that happens you're going to sit
your ass down in a chair
in congress and you're going to confess
to
creating the virus that's killed almost
a million americans now all on your
watch sir
and then we're gonna figure out he's
talking about fouchy again just as a
reminder all the special deals you had
with all those grant money things and um
we're gonna fit you for an orange
jumpsuit tony you can count on that so
so don't be smug on cnn dude
okay so this is all a reaction to a
comment that dr fauci recently made dr
fauci was asked you know he served uh
under donald trump
he was made chief medical advisor under
joe biden and he was asked if trump
comes back in 2024 would you serve under
trump and fouchy essentially said no now
i actually think that it's sort of a
non-question anthony fauci is now uh
what is he is he 81 uh he's 81 years old
uh if and when trump comes back he would
be close to 85 years old i anticipate
that dr fauci is going to be retiring in
the next few years so at the end of the
day i don't really believe it's even a
choice dr fauci would be making uh will
i or won't i stay under donald trump i
could be wrong but it is to some degree
a political statement i mean dr fauji is
saying it was so crazy trying to deal
with covet under trump that if trump
comes back i'm out that's fine
why is the right obsessed with going
after medical doctors
well one of the answers is their
political ideology that they espouse
since the start of the pandemic be very
skeptical of vaccines be skeptical of
masks be skeptical of whether staying
away from people physically even really
prevents the spread of the virus being
skeptical about the fact that this is
much more deadly than the flu all of
these different things all of the
political position all of the medical
positions that they staked out were not
really medical positions they weren't
really science-based positions they were
political positions made to perpetuate
their own ideology of so-called freedom
and all these different things and to
make donald trump's failed response look
less bad or to even look good if you can
imagine it and so when that's the
political position that you stake out
you have to make those who have a
different view your enemies and the
medical science community had a
different view the medical science
community had views that differed about
guidelines safety guidelines vaccines
masking all these different things and
so you have to make them your enemies
and that is a it's a feature rather than
a bug of modern reactionary politics
it's not just
you know we kind of have like a
different perspective about
the correct level of taxes or whatever
the case may be which is like okay well
we can disagree
but it's not
as i mean
i would argue it's pretty clear
what is better economically when it
comes to taxes but there is more of like
an ideology associated with it and the
spirit of what the government should be
doing in terms of taxation okay with a
lot of these cobia related things it's
just the science that's all it is
and when you are basing your politics on
reactionary fear-mongering and arguing
that those with a different view are
evil and on and on and on when that's
your perspective
you have to attack everybody and make
everybody your enemy and so doctors
become your enemy and that's exactly
what we're seeing now i want to go back
to the obvious hypocrisy
trump called it the china virus china
did it china created it but at the same
time they want to blame dr fauci it
seems like hypocrisy but remember
hypocrisy has no bottom or no top i
guess depending on your perspective with
the modern right wing so what will they
come up with i am sure that they will
say well now
fauci
had and funded
china creating it
that's how they will square the two uh
peter navarro really makes
my pillow mike lindell
seem like kind of a reasonable guy he
makes him seem almost sane and the
really scary part is that the rhetoric
is becoming more overtly violent
even now talking about imprisoning
or going after medical doctors and
they're doing it all out in the open
it's becoming normal it's
extraordinarily unsettling how
comfortable the modern american right is
with threats of violence threats of
suspending due process and just just
jail people just put them in jail very
very scary stuff
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
i did this story yesterday about how
jordan peterson attacked me for a video
i did about him i got a voicemail about
that let's listen to the voicemail then
we'll talk about it
hey david dale from denver again i'm
just calling regarding the jordan
peterson uh click he put on youtube yes
uh the question i would ask dr peterson
is
you think it's bad to demoralize them
and by telling them the truth and the
reality what's going on
but is that actually better to lie to
them about that than it is
to tell them the truth so they can face
the truth and
maybe come up with a solution yeah i
mean listen this is basically the point
i made
jordan peterson wept
because he felt today's youth are being
demoralized and their lives are being
ruined by being told
as humans we're up against some hard
problems and one of those problems is um
climate change caused by
industrialization burning of fossil
fuels and human activity on planet earth
jordan peterson says it's demoralizing
to tell young people that and they're
almost being told peterson claims that
they are morally bad because these are
problems that we're facing my view is it
would be immoral not to tell them that
if we want to solve these problems to
some degree young people are going to be
the people that when they are not so
young are going to be in a position
hopefully to solve some of the problems
that we're dealing with if we hide the
fact that these problems exist from them
how are we doing them a service we're
doing them a disservice i would argue
and that's uh i i believe that's what
the caller is arguing here as well i
agree with the caller i disagree with
jordan peterson jordan peterson as i
told you yesterday after flipping out on
me said that an overweight woman is ugly
and then quit twitter
so it was a wild week on twitter for
jordan peterson we have a great bonus
show for you today
here's a fascinating study that was done
americans who do not currently have
student loan debt were asked
do you support joe biden for giving the
student debt of people who do have debt
and overwhelmingly those without student
debt said yes i still am in favor of
that i don't have student debt and i'm
in favor of it i'll explain to you why
on the bonus show secondly u.s soccer
has agreed to an equal pay deal for the
men's and women's players very
interesting we'll talk about it and
there's a lot to discuss related to it
and for those of you who remember martin
shkreli martin shkreli is this sort of a
dark figure who is mostly known for
buying a pharmaceutical company and then
exploding the cost of the drug that the
pharmaceutical company
manufactures he actually was just
released from prison not related to that
but related to some financial crimes
that he uh was convicted of
he has now been released from prison and
we will talk about the hero's welcome
that he's getting in some places not
everywhere though all of those stories
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access
and remember that on monday memorial day
we'll be doing a one-day membership
special trying to bring in as many new
members in one day as we can if you'd
like to be notified when that membership
discount is live
just sign up for my newsletter the
newsletter is free at davidpakman.com
and you'll hear from me on memorial day
with very specific instructions and of
course
everybody who signs up gets access to
the bonus show oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad right okay we'll see everybody on
the bonus show or tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below